[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today chrisy
starts this hour in Louisville Kentucky
hi Christie welcome to the Ramsey
Show hello Hi how are you doing great
thank you all for taking my call really
appreciate it sure what's
up okay well I used to be a single mom a
three divorcing and my plan was after
got the kids out of the house cuz
my budget was really tiny to start
tackling my student loan debt and
purchase my house that I live in for my
parents for what they put in it to to
get it going for me and um two years ago
I and kids are out of the house now so
two years ago I've
remarried and I knew my husband had some
credit card debt from his prior
marriage however um and I know things
have been tight since we've been married
it's like we're Robin Peter to pay Paul
robing Paul to pay Mary and after
listening to y'all for the last couple
weeks I'm here like I can do this um do
the budgeting app the the every dollar
the free
version I can we can do this however we
sat down he's got 22 credit cards hey
yay yay
well how much does it that's an crap
moment got his car oh I'm sorry that's
an old crap
moment yeah so this is where a lot of
our money's going to you know yeah yeah
how much does that how much does he owe
on these 22 credit
cards
18,000 and I guess he knew
this I'm assuming he did I hope he did
what what was reaction to your
reaction um he's like well um maybe you
know after the holidays take a debt
consolidation loan and yeah because you
can always borrow your way out of
debt right that's dumb okay what was his
reaction is he ashamed of this does he
think he stupid did he feel
defensive um he was kind of defensive on
it a little bit because a lot lot of it
he say come from his prior
marriage so he's not is he currently
using credit cards or is all
old um he used it this past weekend he's
still using them yeah okay put a battery
in his car so you guys have some
conversations to have so what is your
income and what is his
income okay mine is 33,000 a year mhm
he's doing door Dash so it's
anywhere six days five to six days a
week um why does he not got a job that's
a good question he likes working on his
own he says did he have a job when you
met him or he was doing this when you
met him um whenever I met him he was
doing LIF to Uber Nashville okay and
making 1,200 a week on that gross before
taxes
and wear and tear on the car exactly he
might be breaking even
mhm okay so there's some problems here
how much student loans do you have by
the
way
110,000 stud loans okay yeah so
sometimes when it sometimes when we get
into debt it's as easy as saying all
right I make my budget and I cut back
here and there and I you know over time
I'm out of it and then sometimes there's
more to the equation where there's an
income side of it where you can side
hustle till you're blue in the face and
you're going to be working it forever
and in that case that's kind of where
you guys are this core your core income
is not where it should be and the
challenge here is for both of you guys
to really begin looking at what's it
going to take for me to get my income
higher I mean 33,000 is the average is
67,000 so you see where you're at on
that on that Spectrum what do you do
for um customer service who got $110,000
worth of student
loans that's me and getting a degree in
what psychology and counseling because
that was the quickest thing I could get
I've always wanted to
teach and why are you not utilizing that
in some
way um I really don't know if any job in
our in our little local area for that
degree without getting a masters yeah
okay
it is probably limited because if you're
going to do counseling in Most states
you do have to have a master's okay yeah
but there's not there there's a lot of
things you can use psychology for uh for
instance you can move into the marketing
area of a company and make three times
what you're making so Jade's right um
how old are you to your kids are grown
you're 40 or
50 yeah I'm 46 he's fixing a turn 50
okay all right so this is the time that
you all have the
first most lucrative careers of your
lives and the both of you have to decide
what that is and start working on it you
don't want to be an 80-year-old Uber
driver
mhm this is not a plan you don't want to
be doing door dash at
76 this is not a
plan you don't want to be in customer
service at
76 especially when you're looking at
110,000 in student loans and 18,000 in
credit cards and everything you do like
put a battery in your car looks like
more credit card
debth something's got to change would
you
agree oh yes yeah so I I'm with Jade I
think you guys do need to get on the
same page and I think you need to make a
commitment to borrow no more and to
begin to reduce these debts and you're
going to have to rethink both of your
careers because you're going to
struggle this is going to be very hard
20 years in front of you MH very
difficult if you guys do not deal with
this core issue MH you can try to ignore
it but it's going it's the elephant in
the room it's going to stomp around and
leave the furniture broken yeah you
making is this making sense to you yeah
you've avoided this and kicked the can
down the law down the road as long as
you
can and now the can has come home and
hit you in the back of the head like a
boomerang 110,000 on student loan debt
how long ago were you in
school um graduated
2009 no 13 15 years was my guess I
wasn't far off okay yeah see it's time
to deal with this do you agree oh yeah
kids are grown and gone okay so we're
going to get out there credit cards
we're going to have a plastic surgery
party tonight honey we're chopping them
all up every stinking one of them this
has to
end that's how I would have reacted had
we found this okay it wouldn't have been
as nice as you you're a little sweeter
than me this is stupid it has to stop
how about that one let's try that I like
it there we go this is the ramsy show
create your free every dooll budget
today the simple way to budget for your
life